alors rubinica alors elle était venue
nous voir une fois et parce qu'elles
vendait l'autre son bain quoi 1500 € le
vote vous l'avez encore beaucoup ou pas
franchement un mec je pensais pas du
tout que j'allais avoir autant de
commandes c'est incroyable en ce moment
je m'en mets plein les poches
c'est incroyable de dire ça Marco tu con
elle vend l'autre son bain qu'est-ce
qu'on pense je suis en connait un qui a
envie de l'acheter mais il a pas
d'argent
ouais
vous comprenez quelle bande l'autre sont
bas ou pas ça c'est un beau business ce
que vous vous êtes loin mais j'aimerais
bien avoir des fous cachette ça ouais
mais vraiment des fous qui achètent ça
vraiment
vous entendez au moins une par jour
presque c'est incroyable
déléguer un peu mon travail vraiment
j'ai du mal à gérer j'ai énormément de
trucs
non franchement il a raison par jour
vous avez du mal à gérer un mois les
Lamborghini à moi la Villa vraiment je
suis hyper contente là
non mais c'est vrai rugby là
qu'est-ce que tu penses de cette idée
devant de l'autre son bain toi qui était
moi j'ai une question c'est le même bain
des qui a
merci il était au cagibi celui-là
qu'est-ce que tu en penses de ça toi
ça va tu suis un peu l'émission est-ce
que vous vendez
à l'intérieur
non sérieusement c'est sérieux oui je me
fais du bien dans le bain d'accord et
d'accord voilà d'accord moi chacun son
métier hein
Fabrice tu commences à café ça fait une
polémique ça cette histoire de l'autre
son bain ou pas franchement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci
ta réponse est la meilleure franchement
attends sérieux on va revenir à toi on
va